you all were ready to start now than
we'd all be together on that the chapter
that you've been assigned for this week
deals with Greece Iran and India in the
comprehensive version of the book as
opposed to the brief Edition that we are
using this is two chapters chapter on
Iran Greece and Iran in a separate
chapter in India and Southeast Asia in
order to make the book shorter we
decided to dump early Southeast Asia and
to lump India in with Greece and Iran
hoping to pick up Southeast Asia at some
later point because everything in world
history up that level has to do with how
many words you have how many pages do
you have and how do you you know how do
you make compromises in the area of
coverage but in fact we had in earlier
stages debated the whole relationship of
India to Iran to Greece and that debate
had oh you know shown up in some of the
early manuscripts of these relevant
chapters and in different appreciations
among the authors of some of the debates
in current historical thinking and here
I'm particularly thinking about the
question that in the broadest sense is
the question of people a supplanting
people B or B supplanting C or C
supplanting D whatever where you have a
sequence of people who live in the same
place
and the later ones will typically create
histories that route them in that place
and a much earlier point in time than
they were there and the earlier people
to the degree that they are able to will
often push back and emphasize that they
were there first and that priority of
occupation is a is a priority of virtue
as well as a priority of time so for
example you know Christians in Spain
will point out that they were that there
were Christians in Spain before the
Arabs invaded Spain you have a huge
debate over the question of who has the
priority rights to Palestine or Israel
or the Holy Land or whatever you want to
call that wretched piece of ground there
are debates like this in all parts of
the world sometimes they are have very
powerful political resonances sometimes
they are more within the historical
community sometimes their debates that
rest on questions of who is called what
what terminology is used so that for
example last week you read about the
Sumerians and the Hittites you know two
ancient peoples of the Middle East in
the 1920s when there was a Turkish
Republic established after World War one
that Republic founded by Muslim Kemal
atatürk had a very strong economic
philosophy of state capitalism so they
set up large state Development Bank's to
provide the money to develop the country
and to of the banks they set up we're
sumaré Bach and Ettie Bach the Sumerian
bank and the Hittite Bank as if these
terms that related to people's who had
ruled in the area let's say Oh at least
a thousand in supplicating in the
kisssss barians like 4000 years before
the church ever arrived in Turkey
somehow they were names that they could
appropriate and in association of that
you had a a linguistic theory that came
out from certain scholars in Turkey that
there were there were some languages
that there were certain languages that
were fell into a family the son language
family that showed they're all related
and the hittite and Sumerian lo and
behold were related to Turkish no
non-turkish zoologist or linguist has
ever agreed with that theory nor is the
theory pursued now by Turkish scholars
but it was a part of a of an effort at
that time to to create a myth of early
occupation in which the Turks would be
original inhabitants of a land that was
in fact full circa 1920 of Greek
Armenians who had much better claims
historically to have been early
inhabitants bland you had something
similar in in Lebanon in the 1960s where
you had certain Lebanese who said we are
not Arabs true we speak Arabic it is our
native tongue but we are Phoenicians
because the Phoenicians had a great
civilization focused on towns that now
exist in Lebanon and ruins or later
occupation Sidon and tyre and byblos and
so forth and also in the city of
Carthage in Tunisia said we were one of
the greatest peoples in the world and at
a time when these Arabs that we have
next door to us from Syria were you know
sort of walking around naked in the
desert trying to find a camel to ride
and of the Lebanese Phoenicians were
politically strongly anti Syrian whereas
you had Syrian nationalists who maintain
that Lebanon was an intrinsic part of
Syria so that so these contemporary
political arguments I mean contemporary
at any given point in time often use
myths of origin
or historical constructions of origin
for for political purposes
in the case of Greece and Iran and India
the issue that has arisen has to do with
people who are believed by most scholars
to have moved into all three regions
from somewhere else and they're the same
people these are people who speak in no
european languages and in the case of
the Indians and the Iranians they belong
to a subgroup who of this who speak into
Iranian languages and who are known as
the Aryans
this word is the word that you actually
have an ancient Indian and Iranian
languages it is not a some sort of
backward borrowing you know from the
Nazis I mean the ancient Iranians to
know the Nazis are going to appropriate
the word and it has a substantive
evening of noble but basically if it was
a name people used for themselves
now the other terms indo-european and
into Iranian are scholarly inventions it
was an English scholar who worked in
India Sir William Jones who sort of
first formulated the notion of
indo-european the indo-european language
family but the resemblance between
Persian and certain European languages
and Indian languages had been noted
earlier than that particularly by my
travelers merchants there was an earlier
theory for example that the original by
Dutch scholars after they start to
travel around the world after 1600 on
the creation of the Dutch East India
Company there were Dutch merchants who
came to believe that Dutch was the
original language of humankind because
otherwise how do you explain that the
Iranians so far away in Persia speak
what is essentially a form of Dutch and
the Indians speak what is essentially a
form of Dutch and but in a more
scientific fashion who was with Sir
William Jones with this indo-european
family is
is conceptualized it is a family
eventually before that relates languages
from Ireland across to Bengal and it has
been studied in great detail with
careful examination of the way in which
one language spins off from another in
sub families like the Germanic or the
romance so forth and so on I won't go
into that within this big family of
indo-european into Iranian is a
subfamily and it is a family that is
thought to be a late appearing family
and like the other indo-european
languages probably has its roots in the
area of north of the Black Sea of what
we now call Ukraine but what is now
Ukraine I should say and they migrated
eastward and then southward into Iran
Afghanistan and northern India according
to the scholarly reconstruction of
things there are many techniques that
have been used to you know to
corroborate this for example one thing
you can do is to take a word that shows
up in many different into European
languages for some thing that is
intrinsically localizable geographically
you can say if all the languages have
this word and if that word
geographically is only located in one
particular place then that must be where
they all languages come from so there's
been a lot of there's a there's a book
on this called proto-indo-european trees
where the effort has been to take the
names of trees and see where those trees
grow naturally is a little awkward
because you have changing climates and
therefore you have to look in the
distribution of pollens and
archaeological deposits to decide where
the trees were and the other word that
has been used a lot is the word for
salmon
with the idea that if basically the
proto-indo-european word for salmon is
locks and but the idea was that these
languages must have originated where
there were salmon all right that's one
technique but of course if it precludes
the notion that you could have borrowing
from some other some other language
family so all of this has been an
extremely elaborate linguistic exercise
which is a difficult exercise because
there's no way prior to writing to
determine where a language was spoken
you can find things that will correlate
with the language that is to say
if you have a language that has a word
for Oh some object say a plowshare then
and you find a place that has plowshares
then maybe the language is spoken there
something of that sort but what has
happened in recent times by this I mean
the last twenty or thirty years is that
there has been in India a very strong
reaction against this theory that the
indo-iranians or the Aryans entered
India from Afghanistan or beyond
Afghanistan from Turkmenistan and the
area's farther to the north the counter
theory says that the Aryans originated
in India and they go from India to other
places why would this be what would we
care well one of the reasons we care is
that this theory became central to the
political philosophy of a Hindu
conservative party the BJP you know as a
as a political statement saying that we
were not invaded by people from
somewhere else who brought their culture
in their religion but rather we invented
our culture and our religion and other
people have borrowed from us in its most
extreme form the argument goes that the
Aryans originated in India established
as a civilization in 7,000 BC so to say
some 4000 years before the Sumerians or
three thousand years before the
Sumerians
and every part of the world has received
civilization from India
you know the Sumerians were just an
offshoot of the Indians the Greeks the
Romans the Chinese everyone gained their
enlightenment their dose of civilization
from this mythical / or holy invented
early India and and so the great Indian
epic the Mahabharata which means the
great Maratha and it's the great bar to
war it's an epic of about a war and
according to this theory this war was
fought something like 5,000 BC scholars
of the ma Bharat a normally questions
whether the war was ever fought at all
or whether it's entirely mythical just
as people questioned a prior to the
excavation of Troy whether the Trojan
War ever really happened or whether it
was it was mythical now what I you know
I have I very strongly that the notion
what's called the indigenous area theory
that is to say the theory that the Aryan
languages and peoples originated in
India and go from there elsewhere
personally I think that that's wrong and
I think that a way in which philologists
and archaeologists have constructed the
migration of indo-european Ukraine into
other parts of the world including India
I think that is a much sounder theory on
the basis of the sorts of evidence that
scholars usually come up with
the reason I bring it up is because it
it is such a hot political issue or has
been such a hot political issue in India
hearing of a theory that says that the
basic Indian beliefs that you have first
in the in the sacred texts of the Rig
Veda and the other Vedas that these
sacred texts were brought in from
somewhere else that the rituals
associated with sacred texts originated
somewhere else and that the religions of
India today Hinduism and you know less
numerous faiths derived in in
substantial part from this intrusive
religion and the Vedas are still
regarded as as sacred texts and the the
caste system that is seen to be
intrinsic to the world of the Aryans the
world of the Vedas is seen to be
intrusive into India so people who
follow the indigenous Aryan Theory say
who invented this idea it was invented
by Europeans and who were the Europeans
who cared about this they were Europeans
who were invading India they were the
British and primarily the British but
other European powers have interests
commercial interests imperialist
interests in India and so they said well
isn't it likely that these Europeans
have invented this story of people
coming from the north who are the
ancestors of the Europeans by common
belief haven't they invented this story
as a as a model justification for their
own
of India and haven't we seen this occur
before when Muslims came to India so
isn't there a theme in which India is a
passive vessel receiving influences from
elsewhere but lacking the dynamism to
generate its own its own culture so the
entire the entire apparatus of well
Western scholarship relating to the
earliest peoples of India and Iran and
Greece is putting the question in in
tune with the political currents that
you have in India today now the
interesting thing with respect to this
linkage of groups in this chapter or
areas of this chapter is that in Iran
which is not next-door to India
literally although you know Pakistan
which it is next door to was once part
of India for under the British was
governed by the same central government
in Iran so far as I can tell nobody
cares whether the Aryans invaded Iran
indeed they seem to think that that's a
cool thing you know they you're more
likely to get the view is a powerful you
know militant conquering people the
Aryans came into Iran and we are their
descendants and who cares who was there
before because we rub their faces in the
mud and now we are done
nor does anyone in Iran to the best of
my knowledge claim that Aryan influences
originate in Iran so here you have two
countries both of which have strong
nationalist movements that are virtually
next-door to each other that share an
identical heritage as far as we can tell
by identical I mean that the earliest
form of the Persian language of language
or the Iranian language we now have
which was contained in the holy book of
the Zoroastrians the Avesta language of
the Avesta which is called Avastin
you know cleverly and the language of
the Rig Veda which is called Vedic those
languages are so close to each other
that if you take a you know a small
number of of sound ships and you simply
make those shifts you actually go from
one language to the other so that an s
in
in a vest them is an H in Vedic and an H
in Vedic is an S and s in Vedic is an
ancient a vestal and you make these
shifts and you actually have almost
almost identically the same language so
there's no there's no real question
about the degree to which the people
there were one time people living in
Iran who spoke the same language as the
people living in at least parts of India
there is question about whether they
were invaders I suppose from an Indian
point of view but the point is that the
Iranians don't care because there
there's no political ground to be to be
contested on this issue you could
imagine an Iranian who would say the
English made up this theory of Aryan
languages in order to dominate us but
since Iran was never part of an empire
they were dominated in some respects by
the English but they were never turned
into a colonial possession in the way
that India was the venom against England
is tends to be much more specific than
at a kind of cosmic level that you have
that you have represented here so
you have this comparison of two places
that where one time spoke the same
language that appear to have a culture
to religion that is merely identical
that that culture and religion are
carried by people who seem to come in
from someplace else geographically and
yet from the point of view of a world
history book this question of are these
are the interpret chapters I mean one
time I remember make the argument that
we should have a chapter on Iran and
India because they're the same country
and our ancient historian and our writer
team said no no it's Iran and Greece
because you know the Battle of
Thermopylae was between Iranians and
Greeks and it got into this question as
to whether the dominant structuring
factor should be a narrative where we
actually have a history of a war for a
series of wars between Greeks and
Iranians or whether it should be the the
cultural / religious / linguistic /
social structural identity between Iran
and India that becomes the structuring
factor now in some respects you might
say it doesn't make much of a difference
but I would argue that the question of
whether Iran is a country that isn't is
in its history culture language
geography and almost every other way a
part of the territories that lie - its
East Afghanistan Pakistan India
and some of the states of Central Asia
or whether it is part of the Middle East
I think that's a very serious serious
issue we treat it as part of the Middle
East and say when we set up programs in
this country of Middle East Studies all
the programs included Iran but it was
also recognized by everyone that even
though the Persian language was written
in the Arabic script the Persian
language bears no relation whatsoever to
Arabic or the languages spoken west of
Iran neither to the Turkic languages in
the North or the northwest
nor to the Semitic languages directly to
the West it isn't in the European
language it is related languages of
Afghanistan India and going up into
Russia and westward into Europe but the
the territory in the Middle East what we
now call the Middle East is dominated by
languages that are unrelated to Persian
when people
who study the middle-east discover this
they're often delighted because what
they discover is that for an English
speaker Persian is one of the easiest
languages of the world to learn all you
have to do is learn how to read that
that writing system and then you
discover all oh oh that's that's English
or that's laughing or I mean it's just a
remarkably similar language not only
similar in the vocabulary and in the
sentence structure and in the structure
of the verbs but also in that most
wonderful aspect of English of having no
genders for the nouns and having no case
endings so all those horrible things you
have learned in German and Russian and
of the language you don't learn in
Persian and in fact Persian goes even
farther they don't distinguish between
he and she which makes for this
marvelous corpus of completely and Roger
this poetry that has been a you know
special quality of Persian literature
for many centuries so on the other hand
for an Arab to learn Persian that's
pretty hard because it's just so
different but we've lumped them together
why were they lumped together why did I
Ron become part of the Middle East in
the 1950s when we were thinking in
academic terms of how to divide up the
world in the aftermath of world war two
and looking forward to the United States
ruling the world in one way or another
the countries of North Africa were under
the control of France the same Morocco
Tunisia Algeria and the Muslim countries
of Central Asia were part of the Soviet
Union
you know Azerbaijan Turkmenistan
Uzbekistan Kyrgyzstan Tajikistan
Kazakhstan then you had the country's
private to the east that were part of
the British Empire that was India before
partition into India and Pakistan with a
very strong British footprint in
Afghanistan so the Middle East ended up
being the the leftovers the residual
category of those countries where Islam
was a predominant language but there was
no long term colonial overlord it was
where was the Muslim territories that
didn't have any Russians didn't have any
British didn't have any French now you
did have brief domination by the British
from the French after World War one
which I'll be lecture on some day you
know that semester but but these were
very very light touches of colonialism
compared with what you had in North
Africa or Central Asia or or India so
you ended up taking Turkey Iran and the
Arab Middle East and throw them together
in a category that was called of the
Middle East now did that make sense in
geopolitical terms it made sense
particularly in the cold war where the
Middle East was seen as a frontier zone
between the freedom-loving peoples in
the West led by us and the victims of
communist slavery in the East led by the
dastardly Soviets and therefore the
Middle East was a was a contested area
and indeed in the 1950s there was a
active debate over the question of which
way will the Muslims go will they become
will they prefer slavery under the
Soviet dictator
or will they prefer freedom under george
w bush now what will they prefer most
American observers said that they will
ultimately prefer the West because
communism is atheistic but you had one
very important British observer a man
named Bernard Lewis who argued that they
would prefer dictatorship because it is
in their nature to prefer dictatorship
and we see this through the history of
Islam now
that's neither here nor there for this
course except that it has been picked up
by and this is really post 9/11 it's
been picked up by writers historians
some of them
first while honorable people who have
said the Muslim world does not like
freedom or the Middle East doesn't like
freedom and the reason we know this is
because of the fight between the Greeks
and the Persians so you get people who
go back and re-examine the history of
Cyrus and Darius and Xerxes and the
struggle between the Greek city-states
and the Persian Empire and they look at
it in terms of values and they say that
the values of that we have today in
America and other freedom-loving
countries in the West were already there
in you know in Athens and the other
city-states at the time of the Persians
invaded and that Persia stood for for
slavery
and so it's always been that way so I've
given you a couple of quotations from a
book by Anthony pag Dhin who is a
eminent historian from UCLA who who
makes that case explicitly and says that
you know we do not have you know it's
different from from the question of will
the Muslims become up for freedom or out
for tyranny because this something goes
way back before the Muslims this goes
back and says that the people in the
East have always been and so I always
preferred to live under tyranny because
they do not understand freedom and
people in the West have always preferred
freedom historically this makes no sense
at all particularly when you consider
the Greeks were conquered and were
subordinated by the by the Romans and
the city-states all came to an end
plus the fact that the city-states all
had slaves and when they conquer when
they fought one another enslaved the
people they took prisoner plus the fact
that Aristotle in his politics is very
explicit by saying that barbarians by
which he means everyone who is not Creek
speaking are by their nature slaves not
because they're living under a eastern
potentate but because they aren't Greeks
and of course by that token the Romans
were also slaves and everyone else was
not a Greek was a natural slave the
pag Dan's book has been world war was
received with great enthusiasm by
various reviewers but it was not the
only he's not the only person who became
drawn into this this restructuring of
the history and two books were written
only one of which I've actually read
they were written on the topic of
counterfactual history counterfactual
history is history of it's the history
of what did not happen it's a history of
what would it have been like if the
South had won the Civil War but would it
have been like if the Germans had won
World War two what would it have been
like if the black death of 1348 in
Europe instead of killing a third of the
population and killed 95% of the
population so we didn't have any of
these Europeans around to screw up the
world for later centuries these topics
all written are all written about and
have been written about for a long time
and they're usually written by science
fiction writers or writers of thrillers
or things like that and it is one of the
most interesting genres of historical
fiction because of course it is it is
not a fiction set in history it is
rather a complete fictionalizing of the
history so you can read
the cyberpunk authors of Bruce Sterling
and no no Steve no Neuromancer William
Gibson yes they wrote a big historical
novel called the difference engine and
it was based on the idea that that the
digital computer was invented in the
early 19th century only and operated by
steam instead of by electricity and that
all of the transformation all the
transformative power of information
control and management took place in the
steam age as an electrical age and part
of the premise of the whole thing was
that the United States divided into two
countries in the Civil War so you help
separate countries in the south and in
the north
the the number of novels about the Nazis
winning in new Europe is is numerous but
this counterfactual history has always
been regarded as sort of a species of a
fiction it could be argued that we
probably have a fair number of history
books that are regarded as important
sources that are employed affect
counterfactual in the sense that they
were that their invented stories that
that that are received at some point as
being true but probably weren't true or
maybe proven not to be true there has
for example in last 20 years been a huge
debate over whether Marco Polo ever went
to China or whether the travels of Marco
Polo are a fiction that was made up
but what's happening now is that you
have counterfactual history that is
being written by my sort of
card-carrying history professors no part
of this guild I belong to and the two
books that I know of as I say I've only
read one of them are devoted to to the
idea of what if something had happened
that had kept the West from rising I got
involved with this because I had a
colleague who had been asked to write an
article about the Muslim incursions into
Europe that ended the Battle of tour in
732 and say oh if the most if the Arabs
had won that battle then we would all be
you know praying to Allah and he refused
to write the article or he declined to
write the article so then the editors
came to me and said would you write an
article that I said no I think that's
total that was a minor battle
with a fragment of an army and really
didn't have any significant result but
I'll write an article about the siege of
Vienna in 1529 and so I wrote an article
that they didn't choose to publish in
which I said that maybe Europe would
have been a lot better if the Muslims
had won but after the book came out and
I read it I realized that it was a
neoconservative tract and that the whole
purpose of the book was to show how
close Western civilization came to being
destroyed you know if there had been you
know one more regiment of the Battle of
such-and-such or two more ships in the
Battle of such-and-such or if King
so-and-so had died two days earlier than
he did Western civilization would have
fallen because the greatest miracle in
the world
is Western civilization and how do we
imagine how no what would have been like
if Western civilization hadn't hadn't
come into being
now paramount in these books you know
right for the beginning of the book is
the question of the Greeks and the
Persians and the argument that is made
by these writers is that if Persia had
won the wars that have fought against
the Greeks and say if the invasions of
Greece had been successful there would
have been no Western civilization heaven
knows what we would have here at
Columbia if the Persians had won one of
those battles because that is where it
hung in the balance of the Greeks
understood freedom and understood
individualism whereas the Persians stood
for slavery and the rule of a tyrannical
monarch
what this innocence did was to take the
the reality that we had in 1950s and
since that time in which we throw Iran
in with the countries to its west and
read it back into history and say that
that is the most crucial thing thing in
the world now this comes up today in the
issue of whether Iran is an enemy of the
United States and indeed if we were to
lose to Iran in the Great War that Iran
hasn't a prayer of actually
participating in because of a very weak
country but if we were to lose would
that be the end of civilization and I
don't want to predict that because we're
having a symposium a week from Wednesday
on war with Iran and the probability of
whether that might occur and so forth
and this is just sort of advertising for
it but but when you look at a chapter
that throws Greece and Persia and India
together you get this question when you
have a historical story in this case the
story of the confrontation between the
Greeks and the Persians which frankly
really wasn't that interesting in a
popular level until the moving 300 came
out I mean with the 300 it sort of made
all made a lot more sense instantly if
you if you look up at the book instead
of the movie you'll find what Hollywood
did in order to make this Frank Miller's
book the 300 palatable for American
audiences was to introduce sex so you
have a
affair between a an evil sparking
advisor and a noble Queen and so forth
doesn't occur in the book the book is
just straightforward killing killing
killing killing killing and is a better
read than the movie is there's also
people who feel that there shouldn't be
any ninjas of the movie that the ancient
Persians did not have any ninjas but
what you have if you actually read
Herodotus and the story of of
Thermopylae and the Persian invasions is
that you have long descriptions of who
was fighting on the Persian side who
makes up the person see here you have
the soma drinking Sofia pnes who fight
with this of that and here you have the
Thracians and here you have the this of
that and these these words for people
that nobody knew who they really were
but they were fighting in the Persian
army these words carried the same menace
as things like ninja and transgendered
black Giants things like that yo well
what would carry now it's a the
translation in other words of the of a
threat feel that you have and Herodotus
into what you get in the on the movie
screen and 300 he is not not all that
bad I thought I kind of liked it but in
any case a curse we haven't seen the
movie that doesn't just forget that the
but what we've had now is a reactivation
of a historian history and I don't think
instantly you can separate the movie 300
or the the graphic novel 300 from this
this retelling by serious historians of
the fight between the Greeks and
Persians of a fight between tyranny and
freedom but this whole reactivation of a
of an episode in history as a as a
mirror or as a some sort of a paradigm
for the way we are functioning the world
today this is is not that unusual this
is one of the things that historians do
this is something that that occurs again
and again that historians will choose
particular stories or sometimes invent
or at least ornament particular stories
in order to to feed the the current
interest or to take advantage of the
current political confrontations in the
historians environment
crucial to this of course is that there
was a narrative there's no narrative of
anything that happens between Iran and
India in other words we have a holy book
for the Iranians the Avesta we have a
holy book for the Indians the Rigveda
and no story about a war between the
Indians and the Iranians the Malabar at
the war is within the Indian segment of
that indo-aryan society and not between
segments and yet we know that there were
Wars so that the the founder of the
Persian dynasty the fought against the
Greeks was killed in warfare on the
eastern border of Iran but not on the
western border with with the Assyrians
or the Greeks or anything like that
so we know there were Wars we don't have
a narrative and so this gets to me the
next topic I want to deal with which is
the the question of the rise of
narrative in history by narrative I mean
the telling of a story
by historical narrative I'm here telling
of a story that is presented as though
the events narrated actually took place
as opposed to a what you would get in he
sees the ogyny where you have events
that are not thought of historical how
the gods came into being or something
like that you know purely in the realm
of the imagination or the realm of of a
myth and of course when you have a
narrative you have the question of the
difference between myth and history
there is a widespread view that history
is a natural propensity of human
societies that you take any people and
they want to remember their past and to
tell the story of their past to the next
generation
there is almost nothing to support that
assumption
writing comes into existence long before
narrative does and writing even when it
becomes fairly sophisticated rarely
focuses on historical narrative there
are parts of the world that have had a
sophisticated literate culture
particularly India that seemed to go for
Oh thousand years without anybody
writing down any historical events now
that there are different explanations
for that some people say well they were
written down that they are written on
imperishable materials and therefore we
don't have them another argument is that
the stories were passed on by word of
mouth and we're not written down because
writing was reserved for for other
purposes another one is that people they
didn't care to tell the story of the
past and you know if you built the
latter option is fairly attractive in
other words if if you're given a chance
to watch The History Channel as your
primary source of entertainment as
opposed to watching something like you
know World Wrestling Federation reruns
or something most people will go for the
wrestling
because the historical narrative mixes
the dull with the dollar and it has to
be either you know spectacularly
riveting in its presentation or the
story has to be redacted with all the
dull bits cut out in such a fashion that
it really makes good reading in order
for people to be to be drawn to it
history books are not very popular on
the whole at least mine but historical
novels are you take say Pillars of the
Earth by Ken Follett and you have a
historical novel of the 12th century
that has a huge following even though
it's a thousand pages long 800 pages
long
ken palette is a thriller writer he's
not a historian and you have lots of
other books written about the 12th
century that nobody reads those are
history books
ken Follett writes it as a story about a
family with you know amazing things
happening and so forth and so on
it's a pretty good historical background
but but it's still enough so the
question is whether stories about the
past whether historical narratives are
really something that a society wants to
do some of the earliest narratives for
example show up on the walls of the
Assyrian Kings in Mesopotamia and what
they are are narratives of the people
the names of the people that became
conquered now here we presume that it
wasn't the
the plan to write something that was
going to be a page-turner but rather
that the king who wanted to have
pictures of himself in glory and
pictures of his captives
subject to his command he wanted the
story the basics of the story related
simply for his own grandeur and there is
a kind of history of that of that sort
where the purpose of history writing is
to aggrandize the person who's paying to
have a history written number of years
ago I had a class and graduate students
and we read a bunch of history books and
each week we talked about how does this
book relate to the biography in the
background the nationality and the
political outlook the religious bias of
the author and the students came adept
at sort of reading between the lines and
saying well here we can see apply this
office presenting the story in this
particular way and so at the end I said
now so we've had a semester we all more
or less agree that all historians are
biased they all have unstated purposes
and writing their history and you all
want to become historians so we'll go
around the table now and each of you
will tell what our what your bias is
because if you're going to be historian
and evolve story and you're biased then
what is your bias and of course they all
said they had no bias and so well do you
expect to be assigned one when you get
your page that you're going to have no
bias after you get a PhD and then
belongs your diploma we give you a bias
of some sort I did one year and I got a
wino table and there's a Korean students
that I going to write nationalist
history of how great my country is and
the students looked at him and said
chief that's primitive he said you see
you all come from countries that already
have nationalist history but my country
was under Japanese occupation and it
doesn't have a real you know gung-ho
nationalist history and therefore we
can't have a revisionist
anti-nationalist history until we have a
nationalist history so I'm going to
write the heroic nationalist epic of my
great nation of Korea and then that the
next generation of historians come along
and say that I'm biased and I thought
that was a pretty good a pretty good
response to the question but but it's
something that we're continually
conscious of and using historical
sources is you know in who for whom was
the narrative written what was the
audience was as it was there a
particular patron what was the who was a
payoff for the author and so forth and
so on so when you get to an inscription
glorifying an Assyrian King it's pretty
easy you can say this was written by
someone who got paid to glorify the king
then you get to the Greeks and this is
of course where you get a narrative
history of a what we would consider a
modern sort this is a reason Greeks like
Herodotus and facilities are looked upon
as the fathers of historical writing you
know here you've got narratives that
seem like modern history books and are
usually regarded in history departments
as principal documents in the history of
historiography
and say what why do these exist why do
we have these stories when other
countries don't do that of course one of
the things you do is say well what else
was there in other words if history
writing comes along and ultimately
people regard history writing is
important what were the options well of
course one of the options you had for
the Greeks was where the Iliad and the
Odyssey you had epoch where you had
stories that were narrated aloud but
we're not written down and that raises a
question of the relationship between
oral history and a written text this is
an issue that we still have you know is
there a different value that you get
when you have an oral text as opposed to
a to a written text now in some cases
it's a question of error for example the
the Rig Veda was a purely oral text for
probably at least a thousand years
before anybody wrote it down and was
used by was memorized by priests in
India what are now India Pakistan and
Afghanistan and it has believed now by
scholars to be almost completely
unchanged and to say it was every every
syllable every vowel every consonant is
regarded as being
as having a very very high likelihood of
being exactly today the way it was in
say a thousand BC now the reason is that
we know that when you have preserved in
the Indian tradition is the technique of
memorization so that every verse was
memorized then it was memorized
backwards that it was memorized sort of
inside out you would have several
different readings of the same verse
that you would simply get by memory and
the readings had to had to dovetail and
so if you heard someone read it wrong
you would know simply by your own
memorization of it oh you know exactly
where it was wrong by contrast the
Avesta is a very questionable text there
are a lot of guesswork as to what what
certain words are in the Avesta because
memory traditions you know will vary
quite a bit in the case of the Iliad and
the Odyssey you have a different
phenomenon instead of trying to preserve
exactly the words that Homer initially
wrote or spoke or that someone other
than Homer but using his name in ancient
identity-theft either spoke or wrote
instead of trying to keep it at
precisely the same words the technique
was to have catchphrases
that could be used to fit into the meter
so that different people would tell the
story in different ways the verses would
be slightly different and these would be
some you know at banquets and the the
purpose of them was not to give a
precise narrative so much as to be a
stately entertainment for people who are
attending a bank
so here you have a different notion of
the audience that this this technique of
oral composition has been extensively
studied the last generation of the place
you start following this is a book by
alfred lord called singer of tales which
breaks down the Iliad in the Odyssey and
compares them with oral composition of
of sagas in the Balkans in the 20th
century and it's now generally agreed
that that these stories were valuable
that different singers would sing them
in different ways and that there are
certain aspects of it that that that
show this in the same way you take an
epoch like the Mahabharata and that
probably was the same thing even though
it's enormous ly long there's a theory
that's saying that there are two
different verse structures in the
Mahabharata there shlokas and christians
case you're interested but but that the
original story is low is in one verse
form and the all the ornaments come in
another verse form and that if you only
read the trish tubes then you get the
real ma bar so the original one and
everything else is added on you can go
to the Analects of Confucius and find
the same issue of where did these things
come from how were they related and so
forth and sought now what happens in a
written tradition is that all of the
issues relating to - avoidance of error
or maintenance of a sense within a
flexible environment that would allow
change what would wouldn't call that
change error all of those things get
over taken by by the existence of a
writing system where suddenly you shift
from flexibility
and the conveyance of sense rather than
a precision to the issue of accuracy
particularly in the thinking of modern
scholars who are trying to reconstruct
what early text was and often assume
with doubtful accuracy that that text
actually can be reconstructed in
traditional form so with the Persian War
of Herodotus you get one of the first
narratives and if to some degree does
become a kind of a model of how to write
history as opposed to tell stories about
the past or tell stories that mingle
information about the past with invented
tales that are better appreciated by
appreciated by the audience than the
particular details contained in the text
so that gets to to the issue of the
transformation that comes about through
writing I haven't talked much about
writing but I want to next time and
particularly this period where you have
the Greeks the Iranians of the Indians
is a period when you having a great
transformation in the nature of writing
because of the coming of the being of
the alphabet and the disappearance of
earlier and more complex writing systems
that had been characteristic of
Mesopotamia and Egypt and other lands in
that part of the world and contrasting
that with the situation in China
where you have a writing system that
comes into being by say 700 BC and has
no challenge it's one of the strange
thing about strangest is nothing in
history is strange it just happened one
of the interesting things about history
of writing in China is that we have no
evidence that there were ever any other
writing systems in any part of China in
other words you know where as Egypt and
Iraq which are just a stone's throw from
each other have totally different
writing systems and the Mycenaean Greeks
with linear B have a totally different
writing system all within a fairly
constrained area and here in China over
the entire area of China the only
writing system that is known are Chinese
ideograms from 700 BC onward so the
question of what does a writing system
do to a to a tradition is and how it
obviously comes to empower the writing
of of historical narrative is where I
want to start on Thursday